we are going to play lessons in lyrics I
have gone into the Andrew McMahon vaults
terrified by damage where you have
coming down yeah these are 10 songs that
I pick I do know the feeling that you
wanted to convey when you wrote these
lyrics we're going to start with fire in
space sure all right
there's a million city lights but you're
number one
[Music]
the goal with the lyric was to sort of
say okay well you have these nights you
have this life and I'm blessed have this
crazy life with so many characters in it
but it's sort of where home is and what
brings me back homes that's what really
counts I don't use like well in the end
of one of these nights I don't just go
and pass out in a pillow and wake up a
day later because it was crazy it's like
I I'm still awake to see my like
daughter and my wife you know and and I
think there was it was that sense of
like it's love that makes that that
energy actually real we are going way
back home we reflect oh yeah the
break-up song somebody they worked with
ah yeah it wasn't it wasn't meant to be
romantic but it was sort of characterize
I would you know not to reference the
lyric again but it had gotten to be this
ruthless event what I was trying to
communicate was like I can still get my
teeth out of some unfortunate which they
did have you reconciled with that person
I think they think you did restless
dream
[Music]
a letter for the thing that never starts
I love that one it's this idea of like
you know they're always there people
that you've dated or people that you've
had in your life that you know even as
those things have resolved themselves
and everybody was on you know that you
can have these moments where you're like
oh my gosh you know we're like in the
pains of an old love or whatever it's
actually one of my favorite songs if not
my favorite song on people and things
like that trash
oh and it did and I was right and I are
gone
that song was like very specifically
about what Rihanna's where the first
Jack's Mannequin tour we're gonna yeah
we're my it was this sort of pivotal
moment where my wife and I the my issues
my girlfriend it was she wasn't my girl
who were broken up but I sort of cast
the olive branch to like try and win her
back
that's how that holds what that whole
song is really about is this a crazy
night in Tucson where I like I called
her said can I fly home and take you to
like Disneyland and it was sort of the
beginning of this reconciliation process
and it was that Jack's Mannequin era
where I sort of like shaved my head and
freaked out and broke up with something
corporate and broke up with my
girlfriend and that sort of as a
reference of the aftermath and sort of
trying to pick up some new pieces
hurricane we talked about this one
earlier
[Music]
plants between like three three words in
that in that song that I wrote that but
that's Josh's song imagine his talking
about one of his girlfriends from high
school I remember him showing up to band
practice with that song like Josh and I
always had this like healthy and
sometimes not healthy give-and-take you
know Rover you know who wrote what and
on a hat you know and and who was the
leader of the band all these kinds of
things and that I remember hearing the
song and being like so good I hate all
right swim
and we headed back yeah that's a big one
for me a lot of people think that songs
about when I was sick you know I was
yeah and it to some extent it is but it
was really I mean I wrote that probably
two three years after I was diagnosed I
was going to a pretty fair bit of
post-traumatic stress from having been
sick and fall of the rebellion that goes
along with with being a young cancer
survivor I was depressed there was it
was just a lot you know and I remember
feeling and you know again a
particularly sort of desperate state and
having sort of drunkenly written out
some notes on a paper one night and sort
of waking up in the morning and seeing a
word swim you know somewhere on a
bedside table or whatever and doing like
okay this is a this is the thing that's
going to lift me out of it you have a
survivor's guilt you have all these
things that nobody tells you about you
surviving something you just you were
like what do I do now yeah I might like
everything's changed
I'm not as fearless as I was and not as
confident as I was but I still have a
young person who has to float this big
operation and that song I think was the
mower I think you're going to do this
you're going to own it
Constantine
and with what I did to you have I put
you through much so when you change that
lyrics anything it like yeah revisionist
history I suppose that was just the
quintessential like it's the thing that
every really young person does and when
they're like kind of think they're madly
in love with somebody but it's sort of
this romantic ideal you know and so
there's breakups and fights and you know
and people because in between their
stuff it was just a very hormone killed
age of you know trying to win somebody
and then and then intentionally losing
them and trying again do you ever talk
to the constant king in your life no I
mean not out of any like right there's
no there's no there's no uh you know
ill-will or anything but yeah we just
don't have really have like mutual
friend sorry they watch this guy there's
things that aren't worth giving up I
know but I won't let this get me I will
fight I mean I had been like I had been
partying a lot more than I was I go in
waves you know but this was sort of in a
particularly heavy period and had a
really really rough trip and then if I
can say so uh and and and sort of woke
up in the morning and is it like okay
time to get yourself a check yeah yeah a
lot of musicians
I feel like party and drink so much what
is that about I mean I think there's a
Peter Pan kind of complex that goes
along with all of this stuff you know
like a we're we're fortunate to do what
we do and what we do is we throw a party
every night
I mean it's if you really look at it's
like we host the party every night
there's just an element of you know a
sort of joy you know joyful celebration
every every every night of you know of
the tour and and and and that extends
into so many other areas of the life of
what you do is musician it's not an
excuse but it should these are not like
Motley Crue style right
you know like breaking TVs yeah I mean
we've done that too but not a lot you
know but but it's an easy thing to sort
of slip into dark blue
sirrah bossman desires is Mars and the
water reached the west coast and took
the power line and it was you I mean
that will forever be one of my favorite
songs I wrote and it was I was broken up
with the love of my life and I knew that
we were supposed to be together but I
had had this dream where we were in this
tidal wave and just saw this massive
thing coming at me and ended up you know
in the midst of it all with I know some
support I just see now I wrote and
rewrote the lyrics to sort of manifest
my will which was to sort of piece it
all back together even in the midst of
this chaos and storm but it happened in
this weird way in a hospital room and
and and in the middle of a real sort of
storm you know and and I think that's
the crazy thing about that record for me
the last one Kavanaugh heart and there
was never any place for someone like me
to be totally happy it's so depressing
it was so sad but it's not I mean I
think of that song I just I I was I mean
I think it was 15 years old when I wrote
that song you know and and I used that
park as sort of a touchstone for like
these moments these pivotal moments of
growing out being with your friends and
getting in trouble and you know your
family members in part these like these
life lessons I think there's always
something in me that's always felt a
little bit alien to the culture and the
world around me and you feel like you
found a place where you can feel totally
absolutely yeah you know I'm really
lucky the world I have around me that I
both build odds of relationships and
ones that are symbiotic and and that
that that feed each other
there aren't these one-way sort of
relationships and I think that's
something you learn as you get older by
I feel incredibly fortunate because
that's where I've landed
you
[Music]